اعلم تسمع تحذيرات قمه ال 20 في بالي حول
الحرب الروسيه بقدر ما سمع اليوم صوت
الصواريخ التي امطرت مدن اوكرانيا
وعاصمتها وجيرانها ايضا حيث اتخذت الهجمات
الروسيه منحا تصعيديا الان في ظل اتساع
نطاق سقوط الصواريخ الى بولندا و بولدوفا
اكثر من 100 صاروخ ضربتها اليوم روسيا على
مختلف المدن الهجمات استهدفت البنيه
التحتيه ومحطات الطاقه كالعاده لكن لم
تسلم مرافق حكوميه منها ايضا في نهج جديد
للحرب على ما يبدوا كيف
كانت الاكثر تضررا اذا ما تحدثنا عن
الاضرار داخل اوكرانيا الطاقه خارجا وخدمه
الانترنت معطله والبلاد مظلمه
الروسيه العنيفه فهل هي رساله من موسكو في
توقيت رفعت فيه كياب حده خطابها امام قاده
مجموعه 20 في بالي ام رد واضح على مبادره
السلام التي ادفعوا الغرب باتجاهها في
الاونه الاخيره ام هي صفعه في وجه مجموعه
ال 20 كما قال الرئيس الاوكراني بلودو
ميرسيلينسكي قبل قليل
[موسيقى]